one between magnus carlsen and wesley so
the bar has been over to magnus carl's
inside
could he be winning this game yeah uh it
does look very nice for magnus right now
objectively but
it's still complicated there's still
anything can happen in this game
he does that magnus carson going one
pawn up in the position so
right now magnus one point up on the
board wesley trying to distract him
trying to gain some counter play by
fighting on the other flank this bishop
being overloaded you have to distract it
uh wesley here will he see it
will he find this move rook takes knight
that's a winning move for wesley so
right now
take the knight sacrifice your rook
distract away the white bishop and
suddenly after knight takes pawn you're
attacking the queen and more importantly
you're attacking this bishop he's just
going to take this piece black is now
up two pieces for a rook and should we
find it
he finds the winning move david and oh
my god even wesley playing
early in the morning is going to spot
that i mean wesley is
a a great tactical player so and the
problem is
magnus tries to take this night but the
rook suddenly defends it and now
wesley he's just a piece up for only one
pawn and it's going to be game over
and that is why okay so wesley going for
a different approach
he trades a set of rooks first he did
offer that pawn up he did sacrifice a
pawn back but now with his last move
black
pinning that white bishop the queen
behind it the white queen not defend it
so white's bishop cannot move
suddenly some small hope for magnus
carlsen but with best play this should
still be winning for black those white
pawns are gonna be a
serious headache so okay i was about to
say that was a cool move in the position
if
magnus wanted but he didn't spot it he
just pushes his pawns instead that's the
most dropped his bishop back he could
have brought his bishop back and maybe
he should have done
uh magnus there he could have actually
sacrificed his queen to try and go for
checkmate because black's king
know how it's on a diagonal that's
completely trapped the black king has no
moves if white's bishop can
get onto this long diagonal to check the
black king but okay
now wesley bringing his bishop to the
center he's starting to attack white
pawns
on that right side near the white king
magnus had to step that pawn forward
wesley going on the attack now offering
up a pawn yeah this is good
strategy when you're a piece up the
whole essence is that you actually have
a piece up to attack with and so that's
why
wesley is opening up those lines and
diagonals so that his light squared
bishop can actually participate in the
game
whose position is easier to handle it's
definitely white right now
right and it's all about who has the
simple plan and uh
okay well wesley has made a move he's
developed his light squad bishop
while magnus now going on the attack
he's suddenly playing on the front foot
he's attacking black's rook at the top
of the board not defended also if the
black rook moves away then one of the
bishops might be attacked by the white
queen
oh no but this is a is this even
possible can you not just
bishop take that bishop look at magnus
frowning he knew he knows that he's
winning now
he's shocked by wesley's last move and
stockfish confirms it the computer shows
queen takes bishop wins magnus wins the
game wesley resigns immediately
wesley saw just gives up magnus carlsen
this was a dramatic game he ends up
winning this game and look at him he
looks shocked
yeah i think he's shocked about his own
blunder earlier but also shocked that
i'm smiling there we have it